when you hear the word symmetry
maybe you picture a simple geometric
shape like a square or a triangle or the
complex pattern on a butterfly's wings
if you're artistically inclined you
might think of the subtle modulations of
a Mozart concerto or the effortless
poise of a prima ballerina when used in
everyday life the word symmetry
represents vague notions of beauty
harmony and balance in math and science
symmetry has a different and very
specific meaning in this technical sense
as symmetry is the property of an object
pretty much any type of object can have
symmetry from tangible things like
butterflies to abstract entities like
geometric shapes so what does it mean
for an object to be symmetric here's the
definition as symmetry is a
transformation that leaves that object
unchanged okay that sounds a bit
abstract so let's unpack it it will help
to look at a particular example like
this equilateral triangle if we rotate
our triangle through 120 degrees around
an axis through its center we end up
with a triangle that's identical to the
original in this case the object is the
triangle and the transformation that
leaves the object unchanged is rotation
through 120 degrees so we can say an
equilateral triangle is symmetric with
respect to rotations of 120 degrees
around its center if we rotated the
triangle by say 90 degrees instead the
rotated triangle would look different to
the original in other words an
equilateral triangle is not symmetric
with respect to rotations of 90 degrees
around its center but why do
mathematicians and scientists care about
symmetries turns out they're essential
in many fields of math and science let's
take a close look at one example
symmetry in biology you might have
noticed that there's a very familiar
kind of symmetry we haven't mentioned
yet the symmetry of the left and right
sides of the human body the
transformation that gives this symmetry
is reflection by an imaginary mirror
that slices vertically through the body
biologists call this bilateral symmetry
as with all symmetries found in living
things it's only approximate but still a
striking feature of the human body we
humans aren't the only bilaterally
symmetric organisms many other animals
foxes sharks beetles that butterfly we
mentioned earlier have this kind of
symmetry as do some plants like orchid
flowers other organisms have different
symmetries ones that only become
apparent when you rotate the organism
around its center point it's a lot like
the rotational symmetry of the triangle
we watched earlier but when it occurs in
animals this kind of symmetry is known
as radial symmetry for instance some sea
urchins and starfish have Penta radial
or fivefold symmetry that is symmetry
with respect to rotations of 72 degrees
around their center this symmetry also
appears in plants as you can see for
yourself by slicing through an apple
horizontally some jellyfish are
symmetric with respect to rotations of
90 degrees while cien enemies are
symmetric when you rotate them at any
angle some corals on the other hand have
no symmetry at all they are completely
asymmetric but why do organisms exhibit
these different symmetries does body
symmetry tell us anything about an
animal's lifestyle let's look at one
particular group bilaterally symmetric
animals in this camp
we have foxes beetles sharks butterflies
and of course humans the thing that
unites bilaterally symmetric animals is
that their bodies are designed around
movement if you want to pick one
direction and move that way it helps to
have a front end where you can group
your sensory organs your eyes ears and
nose it helps to have your mouth there
too since you're more likely to run into
food or enemies from this end you're
probably familiar with the name for a
group of organs plus a mouth mounted on
the front of an animal's body it's
called a head having a head leads
naturally to the development of
bilateral symmetry and it also helps you
build streamlined fins if you're a fish
aerodynamic wings if you're a bird or
well-coordinated legs for running if
you're a fox but what does this all have
to do with evolution turns out
biologists can use these various body
symmetries to figure out which animals
are related to which for instance we saw
that starfish and sea urchins have
fivefold symmetry but really what we
should have said Wow
adult starfish and sea urchins in their
larval stage their bilateral just like
us humans for biologists this is strong
evidence that were more closely related
to starfish than we are to say corals or
other animals that don't exhibit
bilateral symmetry at any stage in their
development one of the most fascinating
and important problems in biology is
reconstructing the tree of life
discovering when and how the different
branches diverged thinking about
something as simple as body symmetry can
help us dig far into our evolutionary
past and understand where we as a
species have come from